today we're talking about a fun little
find and a hundred thousand dollar
little heist jake paul tried to pull one
over on you guys but of course the
blockchain doesn't lie and we caught him
and we're going to expose it today jake
paul thought man i really snuck that one
by everybody but he didn't because the
blockchain just never changes so even if
he gets away with it for a week or a
month eventually we catch him and we
will make him suffer
no
that's a little dramatic um listen guys
i'll be honest i i never make any kind
of uh pretensions about saying that
these people will go to jail or that
it's a crime as you know kryptos very
unregulated right now but i can say
without a shadow of a doubt what has
been done here is deeply unethical and
in my opinion the sentence is
you know what i mean like i mean i'm not
saying anything but i'm just saying my
opinion sentence is
there we go so uh in case you were
wondering what i thought about it let's
jump into today's video we're talking of
course about
jake paul sort of the lesser of the paul
brothers
but he's been talking a lot about boxing
all this stuff but behind the scenes
he's been getting into crypto nfts the
influencers favorite grift and so when i
saw
this i got curious f it i just jumped
into this hype and minted my first nft
definitely living in a simulation these
devils are clean af for real
at sacred devil nft sacreddevilsnft.com
now
you're thinking to yourself if you're a
jake paul or you're thinking to yourself
oh boy you got to get in this new nft
that jake's really interested in guys
he's just clean clean dude these are the
first ones he wants to mint so of course
as a jake pauler myself i had to
investigate and what i found out shocked
me jake paul is not actually that
interested in the sacred devil's nft
project he has been paid behind the
scenes six figures for this project to
pump it always guess respect the pump
that's right ladies and gentlemen and
not only that he tried to hide it let me
show you now the first thing we need for
this investigation is to know his nft
account luckily it wasn't hard to find
your mom 169 that's definitely him the
second thing we need is the league of
sacred devils account which is listed
right here now there is no connection
between jake paul and this account and
that's i think important to say it was
hidden through a friend of his named
john marionek this is john's instagram
right here and as you can see he hangs
out with his buddy jake paul a lot they
have similar interests and he calls
himself a marketing and crypto god
now once we find his nft account things
become much clearer here's his nft
account and here's what you need to know
jake paul posted this tweet shilling
this nft project on september 8th but on
september 7th something very interesting
happened the league of sacred devils
that we just found paid john marioneck
his buddy 43 aetherium and the very next
day on the day of jake's tweet september
8th
john marianeck then pays jake paul's nft
account 40 of that aetherium
this leaves three ethereum for john
marianeck himself as a finder's fee but
to put this together league of
extraordinary devils paid jake paul 40
ethereum in an undisclosed
deal that is currently worth 178
thousand dollars to shill an nfd project
i seriously can't believe they thought
they were gonna get away with this by
just shuffling it through his little uh
crypto buddy
john they thought they were going to get
away with not disclosing this now to be
clear for everyone out there who's
wondering what's wrong with not
disclosing well um quite a lot actually
see if i do a sponsorship deal of any
kind and i'm not even talking about like
a regulated stock i'm talking about if
i'm doing a manscaped commercial if i'm
doing a g-fuel ad i have to tell you
guys that i am being paid for it because
obviously you guys listen to every word
i say and if i didn't tell you guys in
advance
you guys might be influenced in a
direction if you didn't know that i had
been paid to make that statement so it
is highly unethical and against most
guidelines for influencers to not
disclose that you have been paid a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars for
shilling an nft project an nft project
by the way which has cratered they used
to do like 400 sales a day now they sell
on average like two to three of these
profiles because obviously all the hype
was just driven by jake paul tweeting
about it and then never tweeting again
because he ultimately doesn't care about
this now i want to be clear i wasn't the
only one who found out about this
kyreel.eth first had the story want to
disclose that sacred devils paid you
30 that was actually more than that
before you made that post and you didn't
add at ftc now when this happened the
guys over at this team sort of panicked
that they had been caught and so two
days after they had done this
undisclosed post they decided to come
clean they said we want to announce
something big as you know jake paul
tweeted us and since then he's minted
several sacred devils we spoke to him
and his team before
he tweeted and we decided to create a
partnership the goal around that
partnership is to be charitable guys and
give back
oh
man if they had only said that before i
mean gosh it's charity guys where have
we heard and a crypto project is for
charity before i don't know
my name's frasier and i support save the
kids token and they go on to say that as
part of this partnership that they
didn't disclose they're going to be uh
donating a jake paul nft and auction it
for charity guys because this deal jake
paul they're about charity giving back
to the community now guys would you like
to know
how much this uh charity nft auctioned
off for i mean bear in mind it must have
auctioned off for a lot because remember
the purpose of this whole partnership
is to be charitable and give back so
would you like to know they're paying
jake a hundred seventy thousand dollars
to tweet about them how much are they
giving back to charity ten thousand
dollars it auctioned off for ten ten
thousand
ten thousand dollars
2.5 eve guys
let's give it up for charity guys jake
paul is supporting charity he makes a
hundred eighty thousand dollars the
charity makes ten thousand dollars and
you guys get some worthless nfts
that you're never gonna be able to sell
frankly this is the grip i keep trying
to explain to everybody and i will
explain until i'm blue in the face and
these influencers no longer have any
credibility when these guys go push a
project they make the majority of the
money so does the project the project
has now uh traded 348 ethereum which is
about 1.5 million dollars worth of
volume right 1.5 million dollars worth
of volume jake paul's made 150 to 180
000 depending on the price you're using
and charities made ten thousand dollars
and you guys have made absolutely
nothing this is a grift ladies and
gentlemen this is what it looks like
they are actively trying to hide it from
you they pay his buddy his buddy pays
him he silently tweets about it doesn't
disclose that it's an ad you guys rush
in
buy the worthless nfts and they run off
with the money is the fbi gonna show up
i don't know what do i think should
happen
that's that's it that's i you know what
i mean i can't i'm not a judge right i'm
not i'm just here to expose these guys
that's my job i'll just tell you what
they did and you guys well honestly the
police
should decide is this a crime i mean
right now crypto so unregulated but you
still have to disclose that something is
a sponsorship so again i don't know
if jake paul is going to go to jail but
in my opinion
sorry i've done that too many times at
this point
i'm just saying i'm sick of it dude i'm
sick of watching these guys take
people's money take their fans money and
then just pretend it never happened
after this do you think jake has
continued to tweet about sacred devils
nft no dude no
he was paid he got his bag and got out
when are you guys gonna realize that so
yeah this
this is a light investigation it's fun
not let's not get too serious about it
okay just a cool hundred thousand plus
heist by old jake paul he thought he was
gonna get away with it but not on our
watch guys i hope you had a great one
thank you for watching more
investigations in the future and i will
see you guys
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling